“4, 3, 2, 1… 0!”
This is footage from the “Operation Ivy”
nuclear test in 1952.
And this is a clip from the movie ‘Them!’
— a film released just two years later about
giant irradiated ants.
And it wasn’t the only film from the Atomic
Age about mutant animals terrorizing the public.
The pervasive fear of nuclear devastation
that haunted the Cold War would manifest on
screen as literal monsters time and time again.
We now understand that radiation is more likely
to poison animal life than to create Godzilla…
but what if that wasn’t the case?
‘Barren,’ a post-apocalyptic worldbuilding
project by Keegan Francis, imagines an alternate
history where civilization ended in nuclear
conflict, and mutated animal life rapidly
evolves to rule over the irradiated wastes
left behind.
A retro-future that calls to mind the worldbuilding
of the Fallout series, the project reveals
a world where human survivors must contend
with biological horrors created by their own
folly.
So, for this entry into the archive, we’ll
travel across the wastes, creating a ‘survival
guide’ of sorts to the creatures that roam
this desolate world.
And if you want to help support and build
this project, there’s a link to the artist’s
Patreon down below.
Now, let’s cross into an alternate timeline,
and witness the broken world of Barren…
We’ll begin with the basics of mutant biology.
In nature, animals change over time due to
random genetic mutations allowing certain
members of a species to better adapt to their
environment and pass on their genes.
The irradiated environments of Barren speeds
up the rate of these mutations considerably.
As a result, animals in this alternate timeline
now evolve to fill new niches with alarming
speed.
Just a few generations after the world’s
end, most species of animals now look unrecognizable
compared to their prewar ancestors.
With evolution sent into overdrive, many familiar
species will die out in this new kingdom of
fierce competition.
Beyond ambient fallout, the most extreme mutations
are brought on by an irradiated strain of
illness called Nukrosis — which subjects
its host to even more rapid evolutionary changes.
While the disease often results in advantageous
mutations, it simultaneously reduces the host’s
lifespan — making it more of a curse than
a blessing.
The Nukrosis infection has become a widespread
issue in various regions, contaminating a
significant percentage of the postwar biosphere.
The region we’ll be exploring in this video
was once the United Kingdom.
Yet the green landscapes of old have been
replaced by a grim wasteland of silent decay.
The people’s spirit remains hopeful, however,
resulting in the region’s nickname: “The
Unbroken Kingdom.”
For among the small pockets of survivors,
hope is the last defense against the dangers
of the new world…
In the new reality of the Unbroken Kingdom,
farms of old no longer exist — with most
domesticated animals unable to survive in
the merciless new paradigm.
Instead, new animals have assumed the role
of livestock in the settlements that have
risen from the ashes.
The mighty Bulwark are a widespread species
of farm animal that are quite docile, despite
what their horns and tusks might suggest.
These mammals are related to prewar cows,
namely the Holstein Friesian (hol-steen free-zhen)
and Highland cattle breeds.
With adults known to weigh well over a ton,
Bulwark are classified as megafauna, and have
the tenacity needed to endure the unforgiving
postwar reality.
Taking a closer look at the Bulwark’s hide,
we can see that their thick, leathery skin
acts as a kind of natural body armor.
While they retain the familiar pattern of
their bovine ancestors, the Bulwark’s protective
hide is closer to that of an Old-World rhino.
Postwar farmers rear Bulwarks on the fertile
fields around a region called “New Yorkshire”
— making the area one of the more prosperous
in the Unbroken Kingdom...
Yet Bulwarks aren’t the only new farm animal
found within the meager settlements of the
Kingdom.
The uncanny Bonehens are a common sight in
this new world.
Their cretaceous-esque features make them
well adapted to the harsh environment, with
the bonehen’s spikes helping them stay cool
during heatwaves.
Bonehens serve as the replacement for the
chickens of the old world — and have changed
much from their tame predecessors.
Their beak is deceptively strong, designed
to crush eggshells and other discarded scraps
for an easy source of protein.
Comparing a Bonehen’s feathers to the plumage
of an old-world chicken, it becomes clear
that the Bonehen’s feathers are significantly
fused and matted.
Their makeup is almost more akin to the hardened
scales of a reptile than the soft plumage
of a bird.
Due to a shortage of food, the surviving government
has released posters urging civilians to rear
Bonehens as a source of sustenance.
While eating a mutated species like a Bonehen
is a viable means of staying alive in desperate
times, the long-term effects of consuming
such meals remain to be seen...
Just beyond the fences, far more dangerous
lifeforms prowl the ruined countryside.
In some regions of the Unbroken Kingdom, hazard
signs warn travelers to stay clear of nearby
Zadger nests.
Mid-sized predators, the Zadgers are a well-known
threat found all across the former British
Isles.
With bone-crushing jaws and a poisonous barb
on the end of their tail, Zadgers are the
bane of unwary travelers who stray too far
from the path.
Yet surprisingly, these deadly animals are
the descendants of the harmless prewar badger,
which grew in size and ferocity to adapt to
an unforgiving world.
Modern Zadgers are almost entirely hairless,
giving them a wrinkled appearance.
Closer analysis of their glabrous (glay-brus)
skin indicates their baldness is likely due
to an amino acid substitution in a hair growth
associated protein.
An analogous prewar mutation had occurred
in naked mole rats, resulting in their characteristic
lack of visible fur; while unsettling in appearance,
the mole rats were not dangerous.
But in this world, with creatures like Zadgers
on the prowl, roaming the wilds can be a serious
mistake.
And more frightening things than Zadgers have
evolved in the Unbroken Kingdom.
For woodland animals aren’t the only things
that have been mutated in the new world.
Some humans have been changed as well, transforming
into a new species of predators.
Characterized by their long frame, claws,
and almost vampiric features, these dark reflections
of humanity — known as the Nukula — haunt
the barren wastes like vengeful ghosts.
The Nukula can vary in many ways — with
most being frail and sickly, forcing them
to become ambush predators.
These slow Nukula hide in ruins of pre-war
buildings, feeding on explorers who delve
too deep.
For the Nukulas still possess their human
intelligence, able to set traps to lure and
ensnare their unlucky victims.
And in other parts of the Unbroken Kingdom,
rarer and more dangerous variants of Nukula
have emerged.
Fearsome Nukula are faster and bulkier than
their slow relatives.
Unlike their smaller counterparts, Fearsome
Nukula are roaming predators as opposed to
their scavenger cousins.
As a consequence of this lifestyle, the arms
of Fearsome Nukula have become larger and
more heavily muscled — and their hands now
end in grasping talons used to ensnare prey.
Their jaws and teeth have also evolved — and
are now strong enough to break through the
hides of the tenacious animals that roam the
countryside.
Analysis suggests the Fearsome Nukula’s
extreme mutations come from the Nukrosis disease.
While Nukrosis makes them apex predators,
the illness also shortens their lifespan — meaning
their numbers are few…
A more common lifeform can be found a bit
closer to the ground.
Dillo-pigs are animals that prove not all
organisms in this new age are quite so frightening.
A pervasive species capable of reproducing
quickly, these animals are often found on
the outskirts of settlements.
Like prewar rodents, Dillo-Pigs proliferate
in large numbers, and are quite adept at scavenging
for food.
Unlike most prewar rodents, however, Dillo-Pigs
have evolved thick armor plating on their
backs to shield against the predators of the
wastes.
These hardened scales resemble the protective
leathery shell of old-world armadillo species
— from which the Dillo-Pigs get their nickname.
Dillo-Pigs are also known to create concealed
nests within prewar ruins, which they retreat
into when threats arise.
And with thousands of miles of abandoned piping
still present underground, Dillo-Pigs have
plenty of room to make their burrows.
Thankfully, the Dillo-Pig is one of the few
animals left in the world that could be considered
pet-like due to their harmless nature and
relatively cute appearance.
Those who make their homes in the ruins of
urban areas must deal with other types of
animals.
Goldwings are a species of city-dwelling bat
associated with the growing region of New
Yorkshire.
Despite their somewhat startling appearance,
Goldwings aren’t aggressive towards humans.
The descendants of prewar bats, they feed
primarily on insects and other small organisms.
Their name comes from the golden hue of their
vibrant wings, which might serve as camouflage
against the ambient light of cities.
Most Goldwings hunt by hanging off lampposts
and staying completely still, waiting for
pests to run into the open — only to end
up as an easy meal.
Because Goldwings feed on disease-carrying
pests, they’ve been marked as an asset by
the government of the Unbroken Kingdom, and
are considered a protected species.
As a result, the hunting of any Goldwings
within the limits of New Yorkshire will earn
offenders a hefty fine…
Just beyond the outer limits of urban areas,
scavengers lurk on the edges of civilization.
The Rotfowl are massive birds that stand taller
than a person, and feed on any carcass that
come their way — no matter how rotten…
or how fresh.
Often seen feasting upon remains from local
skirmishes, they have earned the nickname
‘birds of war.’
The descendent of a pre-war bird of prey,
the Rotfowl have become larger and more terrestrial
than their ancestors — having converged
upon a towering body plan similar to the fearsome
Cassowaries of the old world.
To match their unpleasant diet, their beaks
have become sharp and hook-like.
Yet Rotfowl actually play a key role in decomposition
within their environment.
Like vultures, the function they serve within
the food web might be unglamorous, yet it
is fundamental to various ecosystems.
For Rotfowl don’t just affect the health
of the Unbroken Kingdom.
Studies of their migratory patterns indicate
that Rotfowl travel across the North Sea once
a year, roaming in large groups to other lands
during the height of their mating season.
Genetic mutations are responsible for most
of the fauna found across the Unbroken Kingdom.
Yet the greatest horrors of the wastes are
in fact the result of prewar experiments conducted
by a company called Biophage.
A clandestine organization with a long history
of ethical and moral violations, their story
begins long before the war started.
Originally formed as a pharmaceutical corporation,
the company found its sales began to falter
over the decades.
Everything changed, however, when Biophage
was taken over by one Dr. Ellingham, a successful
businessman with no background in biology…
and no intention of engaging in ethical science.
Under his leadership, Biophage pivoted to
become a company on the cutting edge of prewar
bio-engineering.
The exact nature of the early prewar company
experiments is largely unknown.
And perhaps that is for the best, for what
we do have on record is bone-chilling…
Not long before the outbreak of the war, Biophage,
under the oversight of Dr. Ellingham, began
experimenting with medical rejuvenation.
Unit 1-51 would be one of these many attempts.
Nicknamed ‘Ankle Biters,’ some of these
experiments could be considered technically
successful, as the Ankle Biters were able
to regrow lost limbs as intended.
Yet the result were lifeforms that could no
longer be considered human.
Still, Biophage might have increased the scale
of these experiments were it not for the violent
collapse of prewar society.
Yet not all experiments were destroyed during
the war.
Some creations of Biophage escaped into the
barren waste — and have been able to carve
out a niche in the brutal new natural hierarchy.
Today, perhaps no lifeform in the Unbroken
Kingdom is more dangerous than the seldom-seen
Biophage experiment that stalks the open plains.
Vespores are ruthless bioweapons capable of
horrors far beyond any naturally-evolved form
of life.
While the original intention behind their
creation remains unknown, the results of the
experiment are visible to all.
Vespores hunt with a stinger-like appendage
capable of spearing fast-moving prey.
Once an animal has been speared, the Vespore
then prepares to digest the unlucky creature.
The internal anatomy of a Vespore allows them
to digest prey directly through their abdomen
— making them extremely efficient, as they
are able to feast while on the move.
The terrifying behavior of the Vespore coupled
with its elusive nature has caused it to take
on an almost mythical status in the minds
of some survivors.
For not many see a Vespore and live to tell
the tale…
Aside from terrifying monsters, there is a
quiet sadness that the world of Barren evokes.
It is hard not to read through the project
and feel a certain melancholy for all that
has been lost.
Bustling towns.
Healthy forests.
Clean rivers.
Much of the world as it existed before the
apocalypse has changed utterly, and might
never return to normal.
Yet the people of this alternate timeline
have adapted to the changes, much like the
strange fauna that now roam the wilderness.
The Unbroken Kingdom might be an unfamiliar
landscape, but so long as its people continue
to endure, it will never be a broken one.
There’s much more to the ‘Barren’ project
than I was able to cover in this video.
If you want to see more from the world of
‘Barren,’ you can support Keegan Francis
on his Patreon down below, to access bonus
content and help the project continue.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.